[Musique]
quel charmant petit village avec sa
grand place à mary son église son bar
tabac et ses joueurs de pétanque au et
voilà une charmante petite bergère
il ya également son papa jean monsieur
[Musique]
en fait c'est un coin très sympathique
voilà une tout à coup comme ça des
affaires tous les rats garde moi ça
c'est joli ça avec ses couleurs sa super
non allez tu comprends coucou c'est la
pub c'est faux grèce et tout ça quoi
allez on est d'accord signé la merci à
l'esa licoco ans à peine et ensuite vous
[Musique]
à tokyo on va faire des affaires regarde
ça c'est magnifique ça non mais t'as vu
qu'elle aime pas et hop on est d'accord
signé la mais allez salut quand on
s'appelle et ouzbeks ou lendemain matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
prenons là
oh mais qu'est ce que c'est laid
[Musique]
non c'est vraiment trop moche
en et non le village ne ressemble plus
rien il fonde le maire fasse quelques
champions
[Musique]
messmer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien voilà c'est mieux de la
publicité
d'accord mais il faut qu'elle soit bien
placé et allez arrête de râler coco
téléphone moi et on ira pique nique
merci wet wet
[Musique]
et